نحن نعرف كيف يكون الشعور بالعنف والشعور
بأنك تحمي
عائلتك وشعبك وما إلى ذلك. عندما
خدم ألون في جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
خلال فترة الانادا الأولى والثانية
حتى وصل إلى الاعتقاد بأن جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
كان يضطهد الفلسطينيين
ورفض في نهاية المطاف  للخدمة حاولنا
حلها بالعنف من خلال فكرة نحن
أو هم عندما كان مراهقًا في الضفة الغربية،
ذهب سولان كتي إلى السجن لأكثر من
10 سنوات لدوره في طعن وإصابة
جنديين إسرائيليين، وهناك تم
تقديمه  للمقاومة اللاعنفية
يمكننا تجريد أي شخص من
إنسانيته ولكن في نهاية المطاف صدقني،
نحن جميعًا قادرون على أن نكون الأشرار في
المدينة وأن نكون الأشخاص الطيبين في المدينة، حيث
ألقى حاطب وآلان أسلحتهما
وساعدا في إنشاء تحالف من أجل السلام.
في مكان ما في عامي 2004 و 5 اكتشفنا
أن لدينا هدفًا مشتركًا، لقد مرت 18
عامًا في هذه الرحلة لبناء
الثقة وتطوير اللاعنف
كفلسفة كتحالف
بيننا، ونحن في واحدة من أكثر أو
أعمق النقاط في العالم.
الصراع كنت أرغب في الاستقالة في
7 أكتوبر، فقلت لا، هذا كثير جدًا، لم يعد بإمكاني
تحمله بعد الآن، ثم تلقيت مكالمة هاتفية
من جام من سولي من الآخرين
يقولون ماذا نفعل، أشعر
بإحساس عميق بالمسؤولية
إلى الإنسانية
وآمل أن نكون على اتصال كل يوم
منذ السبت الأسود. أنا أهتم
بعائلتي مثلما أهتم بعائلتي.
لا أستطيع حقًا تقسيم عقلي وقلبي
وروحي بعد الآن، لدينا بعض الإسرائيليين
الذين فقدوا أصدقاء أو عائلة.  لو كان
أحمد هو وقد فقد بالفعل أكثر من
25 أه من أفراد عائلته في غزة
أرى
كل شيء ينهار أه حولنا
لا نعرف ماذا نقول بعد ولكن نحن
هنا المسؤولية الوحيدة التي
علينا هي عدم فقدان الأمل و
إنسانيتنا ما نريده هو حقا تغيير النظام
دون
تغيير النظام حتى لو كنا نتخيل عالما
بدون حماس سيعود العنف
هذه هي اللحظة أه لحل
المشكلة وهي قابلة للحل يمكننا أن
نعيش معا على هذه الأرض بين
النهر والبحر